we had ton like right before he went to
Colorado it was insane he's the best guy
in the world ever love him he is the
number one guy I've met that was totally
different than what I thought I was
getting when I met him in just like the
smartest down to earth
aware like calculating just dude ever
first time you met him what happens I
was impressed instantly like we just
started talking shooting the [__] first
of all some athlet or you paint the
picture for us some so well some some
athletes at his statue or whatever have
an air about him where it's like you're
not sure you can bust balls he he could
take it you could say anything you make
fun of him for anything he give it back
to you just so down to earth and then
the story that got me was he was talking
about his Prime Time character and he's
like well when I was in college I looked
at all the people were getting drafted
in Money Slots quarterbacks and all this
he's like no defense back ever made
money ever got paid so I'm like how what
do I to do to change this invent Prime
Time make myself conscious decision
genius create this [__] marketing
thing and it [__] worked like and
he's dead right everything he does is
calculated smart just he's and he's so
like wildly humble which you wouldn't
expect in the way you can you can bust
the balls like you if he loses I could
text him be like you [__] that play call
he's like yeah I know like he's just he
comes across as one of the guys truly I
don't have and he's had my back through
like if someone attacks ass he's like I
love him like he he's straight he's he's
honestly I can't root for him I knew he
would be successful I knew that within
and when I say that as a college coach
I'm like anybody who could sit with him
and not hire him is a [__] he's perfect
for this age really perfect yeah he's
he's got insane gravity there's some
people that for whatever reason when
they talk the world wants to know what
they're saying whatever they're doing
the eyeballs are on them and he's one of
them now obviously this past weekend's
did you expect this you it didn't shock
me I thought they I I thought they had a
chance to win if we're being honest but
they lost Travis Hunter and he just
doesn't have the guys yet but didn't
Shock Me Do you think that cuz we all
love to root for the the cocky you know
uh the bravado like everybody loved when
Connor was knocking people out and being
confident and the second he stumbles
everybody kind of totally so do you
think that going to happen this week
with with d oh it was all
job listen that will come but I guess
what I'm saying about Dion and I think
he's smart enough if he's like you know
what me being humble and like almost
deferential to other teams or whatever
would help me win he do that like he's
doing what he thinks he has to do to
build the best program yes and it's
working like Colorado's [__] people
are going to forget that was horrible
last year they expected him to be 0 and
three going into that game he's already
been a success no matter what happens I
mean they were like the worst team ever
last year I'm a college football casual
but the only college football memory I
have of Colorado before this year was at
Cordell Stewart Hail Mary in like 94
yeah that's all I got Y in 20 years 30
years whatever it's been that's
it yeah and even look what he does you
can tell a lot by the people who come
back to support him whether it you know
it be Troy Aman one week and then it'll
be Michael Irving the next and it's like
you don't find people who know him who
who say bad things like the people he
spent a lot of time around are all
uniformed like yeah he's [__] the
real deal do you remember watching him
play
yes have you seen anything like it
since no he was a different guy I mean
there was it's weird because I
actually was more like Bo Jackson like
Bo Jackson till he got hurt like I was
like I would be more like Dion can't
hold Bo Jackson jockstrap type guy as a
kid I thought Bo was was also that dude
yeah Bo is also and then you saw Bo play
offense too which is way more exciting
like H Trophy and be that muscular and
run like that a superhero yeah it was
Unreal yeah so for me one now you look
back but for me it's like who is the
original two sport athlete the B nose
campaign all that it was [__] Bo
Jackson even the stories you'd hear
about him are like I watched that 30 for
30 on him uh insane what story just
there was a million of them like these
crazy heroic like you just pick a
baseball up and like throw it out of a
field there's that clip of him in the
Royals game he runs on the wall yeah
runs up the wall
sideways gra yeah it's crazy so but I
remember him but I remembered him more
my memory of Dion was like very
flamboyant like flashy kind of like talk
a lot you know player I didn't really
know the person as much you was probably
on the young side but my roommate said
it well and this was like 15 years ago
but he said every quarterback you've
seen since Dion is just doing Dion yeah
in some form or fashion they got the
long towel hanging out the back they for
a while they would wear that Little Neck
headband around the neck that Deion wear
they're all just doing Dion yeah I mean
obviously you're going to replicate the
most successful like person in your
position but it's just crazy that
somebody who was playing
defense could be the star of the team I
understand maybe a linebacker cuz you're
sacking the quarterback there's like
but the better corner you are the less
active you'll be in the game andeh we're
still watching him he did the punt
returns the dances the videos everything
I remember being I was grew up in Dallas
I was a Cowboy fan anytime Dion was back
to return to punt just you could fit
home the whole family this is it let's
go there's that great uh moment when I
think he's playing for the 49ers and
they're playing the Atlanta Hawks the
first time back in Atlanta sorry sorry
the Atlanta Falcons and his first time
back in in in Atlanta and he gets a pick
six and after the game he goes he he
says some [__] he goes this is always my
home yeah even if I'm not playing for
this team it's my home something like
that I'm just like H what a [__]
Legend to do the post like you could go
after that be like oh I was so emotional
to be here no no keep the character no
he he he I'm a huge fan I'll be a huge
fan of his for Life two your
quarterbacks get not getting paid story
now it's like one of the top five
positions in football and I you didn't
think about that until you said it
that's all back to Dion yeah and he got
branding early like he's like how how do
I make money how do I get you know
contracts like sponsor he got it he got
it smart he had a shoe that was fired
football players never have cool shoes
he was fired Too Legit to Quit him in MC
Hammer right yeah yeah heing R crazy
okay what happens with the Pats before
we get out of here what happens with
does bich win another ring I could tell
you I'm scarred from that game yesterday
against the Jets because I thought Mack
looked good and then this coaching I
don't know what the [__] Happ in the
second half they won the game it felt
like a loss the Jets are so pathetic
they let him in I don't know what's
going on I I don't I I'll say yes but
the tone of voice isn't the most
convincing you got a lot of beasts I
think Matt Jones is very good I don't I
don't know how jacobe Meyers we let him
go to the Steelers and got Juju Smith
Schuster for the same money yeah that
was crazy
yeah it's been a a rough patch having
said that if the Patriot don't win
forever for the rest of my life I'll
take it you're so blessed now what's
your overall perception of bich post
Brady does that Tain his legacy as like
in the coaching at not in your eyes in
the coaching Echelon it doesn't to me I
get a lot of people because I really
think he was largely responsible for the
giant super bowls with the defense he
had was like LT so it's like he did it
there and then he he never won a Super
Bowl without Bel correct yeah Bel W so
uh and like if you remember they
it no I got confused um
so but I can see the argument I can
certainly see the arum they made a
mistake letting him go too early Brady
like he still had years to play then he
goes and wins at Tampa so I certainly
see the argument because the Patriots
haven't been very good
since yeah I mean it's
just the greatest run in the history of
sports the 20 year run they it's been
unbelievable but the Brady thing is so
interesting he was on uh you know
Patrick B David yes he fantastic and he
they did a podcast it was kind of like
live and he had Brady on and Brady was
talking about this competitive like yeah
I saw that was just the other day and
these clips are fantastic yeah I mean he
cried during the Brady six cried talking
about six quarterbacks like on a
documentary crying that they were
drafted ahead of him because that type
of [__] like him talking about how
like it was on some Jordan [__] like I
need the enemy and I need the anger and
once I yeah once I can hate you I can
get out there and be like let's [__]
go but I love that I love I love someone
going out there and and wanting the
other team to hate them yeah and
thriving off of that [__] what motivates
you are you one of those that yo for
sure hate hate is a major like that is
probably my fuel like
enemies and would you create an enemy
that everywhere but I mean like you know
how Jordan would he had you need that
for motivation something a lot yeah yeah
I've always had it so I don't know what
I do without it but it's always there
like that Kenji he's going on a acce of
Spades bottle today like no joke wait
why would happened that's the guy from
the uh I know but what oh I oh you're
not popping it you're just putting him
down there on the bottle and we'll put
it on the Shelf wait yeah